aquí tenemos un triángulo a bs lo que
vamos a hacer es trazar los puntos
medios de cada uno de los lados el punto
medio del lado hace le vamos a llamar de
entonces cumple que ade es igual a de c
el punto medio de seve le vamos a llamar
y se cumple que c es igual a b y
finalmente al punto medio de abel le
vamos a llamar f
voy a ponerle un poco más para acá le
vamos a llamar efe y cumple que bf es
igual a efe
muy bien entonces ahí tenemos los tres
puntos medios y ahora lo que vamos a
trazar no son las medianas del triángulo
sino estas rectas que unen los puntos
medios
efe de condé con efe y al hacer esto se
forma un triángulo aquí en medio el
triángulo d
efe a este triángulo se le conoce como
el triángulo medial de abc y lo que
vamos a hacer en este vídeo es ver que
cumple varias propiedades interesantes
veremos que este triángulo divide al
triángulo abc en cuatro triángulos que
son congruentes es decir cuatro
triángulos igualitos y también vamos a
ver que cada uno de ellos
a bs después con eso vamos a conseguir
algunas consecuencias más o menos este
sencillas por ejemplo que los cuatro
tienen la misma área y que esa área es
de un cuarto del triángulo original vale
pero bueno vamos poco a poco empecemos
con el triángulo de ese este triángulo
parece ser semejante al a b c pero bueno
no es evidente vamos a demostrarlo lo
primero que vamos a observar es el
ángulo a quien se veamos que este ángulo
en celo comparten el de ese y el abc
entonces pues ya nada más faltaría
encontrar o bien otro ángulo o bien que
las parejas correspondientes de lados
tienen la misma proporción pero tenemos
mucha información de los lados así que
vamos a calcular la proporción a ver qué
pasa vamos a calcularse entre cb esa es
la razón entre entre lados
correspondientes
entre cb bueno pues tenemos que ese es
la mitad de cb porque este mide lo mismo
que este de acá entonces cee entre cb es
igual a un medio y de manera similar se
dé entre sea y es igual a un medio
porque despuntó medio de hace entonces
esto es igual a cd
en 13 a va entonces esto está súper
padre porque esto ya basta para ver que
los triángulos son semejantes tienen
este ángulo en común pero además las
parejas de lados correspondientes tienen
la misma razón que es igual a un medio
va entonces vamos a poner por aquí que
por el criterio por el criterio criterio
lado ángulo lado de semejanza por el
criterio de semejanza al lado ángulo
lado tenemos que el triángulo de ce es
semejante al triángulo a b c y además la
razón de semejantes uno a dos
bueno pues esa razón de semejanza
también nos permite determinar la
longitud de d
porque a partir de esta semejanza
podemos concluir podemos concluir que d
entre ave entre ave también es igual a
un medio y por lo tanto de mi de la
mitad de ave pero la mitad de a bs.f o
fbi que tiene tres marquitas entonces
déjame indicarlo acá
y tiene esa misma longitud que es 3
marquitos bueno ya tenemos un triángulo
semejante al abc vamos ahora con este de
acá lo voy a trabajar en color morado
bueno tenemos el triángulo fbi y el abs
y ambos tienen este ángulo en común
entonces vamos a hacer pues básicamente
lo mismo vale ya tienen este ángulo en
común vamos a ver qué pasa con las
razones de lados correspondientes aquí
tenemos que calcular bf entre vean
y observa que eso vuelve a ser un medio
porque efe punto medio y veamos que es
un medio también es igual a b / veces es
igual a b entre bs otra vez porque es
punto medio entonces otra vez podemos
aplicar el criterio lado ángulo lado
criterio de semejanza al lado ángulo
lado y con eso tenemos que el triángulo
el triángulo fbi en el triángulo
efe es semejante semejante al triángulo
al triángulo a b c muy bien otra vez eso
nos da la medida de f porque efe efe /
hace / hace debe de ser igual a un medio
y por lo tanto f emite la mitad de hace
que en este caso es a de o bien de c
vale entonces mide esta longitud que
estamos que estamos marcando con una
rayita sale y vale y bueno ya nada más
nos faltaría de este tercer triángulo el
f
pero voy a hacer exactamente lo mismo
así que si quieres puedes pausar el
vídeo e intentarlo por tu cuenta
bueno vamos a hacerlo entonces en este
caso el ángulo que comparten es el
ángulo en el ángulo f a d es igual al de
hace y además tenemos tenemos que a efe
/ ave a efe / ave es igual a un medio y
eso es igual a a de entre hace ha de
entregarse entonces por el criterio por
el criterio serio de semejanza lado
ángulo lado mira que incluso los
argumentos son muy semejantes bueno por
el criterio de semejanza al lado ángulo
lado tenemos que el triángulo el
triángulo a efe de a efe es semejante al
triángulo a bs o sea el argumento es
igualito vale ya está se volvió
repetitivo pero entonces tenemos esta
semejanza de la fed con el abc y la
semejanza está en razón 1 a 2 y por lo
tanto concluimos que fd mide la mitad de
veces
de la longitud con dos rayitas y ya
bueno sabiendo que todos estos
triángulos son semejantes déjame pasar
algunos ángulos entonces este ángulo de
aquí es igual a este ángulo de acá por
las semejanzas de este chiquito con el
grandote pero también es igual a este de
acá por la semejanza de este chiquito
con el grandote con el abc de manera
similar tenemos que el ángulo aquí a efe
de es igual al abc y el d s d s es igual
al abc y finalmente voy a pasar el
naranja este de aquí es congruente a
este de acá vale entonces ahí ya tenemos
tres triángulos semejantes pero podemos
decir más cosas mira vamos a ver qué le
pasa a estos tres triangulitos de aquí
no sólo son semejantes sino que además
los dos tres
los tres tienen una longitud de una
marquita una de dos marquitas y una de
tres marquitas y no sólo le pasa a estos
tres sino que también le pasa al
triángulo de aquí adentro al triángulo
medial entonces pues qué sucede estos
cuatro son triángulos que tienen los
tres lados
y por lo tanto deben de ser congruentes
por el criterio de congruencia lado lado
lado vamos a apuntar eso por acá tenemos
pobre el criterio por el criterio
de congruencia congruencia lado lado
lado tenemos que el triángulo a efe de
que es importante tener las letras bien
en el triángulo a efe de es congruente
es de amarillo a morado a naranja
entonces es congruente al de s al
triángulo de c y es que es congruente al
triángulo efe
al triángulo efe b
y esto es congruente al triángulo al
triángulo medial pero quiero tener las
letras correctas entonces todavía tengo
que ver pues cuáles son los ángulos
correspondientes y los lados
correspondientes entonces déjame
calcular los ángulos de la siguiente
forma observa que el amarillo con el
morado con el naranja tienen que sumar
180 porque es la suma de los ángulos de
un triángulo y aquí tenemos el naranja y
el morado entonces nada más nos faltaría
el amarillo para que sumara 180 los
ángulos de esta recta de manera similar
aquí está amarillo y morado falta
naranja y aquí está naranja y amarillo
falta morado entonces ya tenemos como
son los ángulos verdad tenemos que ir a
efe de amarillo morado naranja entonces
este de aquí es congruente al e de efe
al triángulo
d
efe muy bien entonces ya vimos que estos
cuatro triángulos hilitos de aquí cuatro
triangulitos de aquí son igualitos son
idénticos vayan son triángulos
congruentes y más aún mostramos que
estos triangulitos son semejantes al
triángulo abc y esta semejanza está
justo en razón un medio y además hay
otras cosas padres que pasan aquí en el
dibujo por ejemplo o sea podemos pensar
a d como una paralela a aa b porque
tenemos nos digamos está transversal la
transversal bc y en la transversal bc
tenemos que el ángulo de s es igual al
abc y por lo tanto como son rectas con
una transversal de ángulos
correspondientes iguales estas rectas
tienen que ser paralelas déjame marcarlo
así esta de acá es paralela a esta de
acá vale de manera similar podemos
pensar
efe hace como dos rectas que tienen a
vea como transversal la vea como
transversal y por lo tanto como este
ángulo es igual este de acá el bebé al
véase
tenemos que estas dos rectas también son
paralelas
entonces está acá
es paralela a esta de acá
no estaría acá y finalmente podemos
aplicar exactamente la misma idea para
efe de ibc con la transversal digamos ac
y el ángulo a df y el acb como son
ángulos iguales y este es una
transversal entonces esas dos tienen que
ser rectas paralelas dejar de pintarlo
así con tres triangulitos va para allá y
esta también va para allá también con
tres triangulitos entonces esto está
interesante porque este triángulo medial
además de ser semejante a la abc tiene
sus lados paralelos al a b se va y
entonces como que la la gran la gran
moraleja de todo este vídeo es que
aunque hayamos hecho unos trazos muy
sencillos en un triángulo que nada más
tenían que ver con los puntos medios de
cualquier forma se pueden encontrar
resultados bien bonitos vale bueno
espero que te haya gustado este vídeo y
nos vemos en el siguiente